[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about a movie that made me wish i got to
moonlight as a fluffy animal during
middle school turning red and pixar's
newest entry explores all of the
pressure and horrors of becoming a young
adult through the story of a girl who
turns into a giant red panda whenever
she gets too emotional oddly relatable
stuff and while i'm pretty sure none of
you have literally transformed into an
ancestral panda during puberty we've
probably all had the experience of being
an awkward and confused 13 year old with
a changing body and raging hormones but
is this movie about more than just that
is this exploration of the dark side of
emotional repression also a window into
the broader world of psychosexual
development let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on turning red
unleashing your panda and spoilers ahead
for turning red which you can currently
watch right now on disney plus who isn't
sponsoring this video but hey they want
to pay we're down so what can an
animated film about a girl who turns
into a panda tell us about the
psychology behind emotional repression
we'll get there but first let's meet our
main character turning reds about 13
year old mei lee nicknamed meimei i've
been doing my own thing making my own
moves 24 7 365. clearly mei's crushing
it oh about the hustle am i right she
has a crew of best friends excels
scholastically can play a rip and flute
solo
and seems to genuinely enjoy helping her
mom manage the family temple and in a
key sign of early 2000's life she's also
deeply emotionally invested in a boy
band much of what's happening in may's
life fits pretty well with sigmund
freud's description of the psychosexual
development of children which is
basically the process where we go from
disinterested in sex to torn up 24 7.
according to this theory around the ages
of seven through twelve children begin
to assert their own independence and
move beyond their childhood ego as they
learn to love and care about others and
may seems to be on the precipice of all
of this and one early scene her friends
urge her to assert herself cancel plans
with her mom and come do karaoke though
mae seems tempted she resists not
wanting to let her mom down on cleaning
day please
can't it's cleaning day may
every day is cleaning day and for the
most part everything seems pretty chill
until that night when may's casual
doodling turns into a pretty erotic
picture of corner store hunk devon it's
clear that may is expressing a type of
unconscious lust or desire which based
on her reaction seems new for her this
suggests she might be entering the final
phase of psychosexual development in
freud the genital stage which typically
happens around 13. and this leads to a
type of anxiety or shame that sends mae
under her bed seemingly hiding from the
watchful eyes of say god or you know her
mom if you grew up religious and ended
up accidentally inventing masturbation
when you were 13 then you know what we
mean and this right here is the film's
first clear example of repression may
tries to hide the drawings from her
mother seemingly fearing that she'll be
judged for her fledgling desire this of
course is exactly what happens mei's mom
can pounce her daughter's shame and
anxiety by showing the drawings to devin
and a bunch of may's classmates the
subsequent teasing only causes may more
anxiety and shame freud can help us
better understand what's happening here
particularly in regards to may's initial
repression of her desires now freud
first noticed repression when his
patients struggled to recall past
memories during analysis he concluded
that this had to do with an unconscious
mechanism by which our human minds push
down and hide i.e repress shameful
memories so we don't have to actively
deal with them that's probably why for
the life of me i can barely remember
anything that happened between the ages
of 11 and 15. and i'm just gonna trust
my unconscious and assume it's for good
reasons this led old sigmund to develop
a theory of repression that involves two
stages first there's primal repression
in which a child realizes that acting on
certain desires leads to anxiety and
other unpleasant emotions the child
subsequently represses those desires
this eventually blossoms into repression
proper in which repression leads to the
development of the superego that's a
sort of self-regulated internal law or
conscience often modeled on a parent or
religious figure this super ego then
bosses around our ego which is the part
of the mind we'd usually associate with
our identity and helps keep our innate
impulses and desires at bay these
desires are what freud calls our id
which is basically the four loko
chugging frat boy part of your
personality in this case mei's id is
expressing a sexual desire for devin but
then this desire results in shame and
other negative consequences so her super
ego starts to create a moral structure
under which this type of desire and
behavior is bad and must be repressed
this will never happen again and her
poor ego now is to try to balance these
two opposing forces of course repression
isn't necessarily a bad thing like if
you have a strong unconscious desire to
strip down your underwear jump up on a
conference table at your next work
meeting while flinging lunch meet at
your colleagues it's a good thing you
have a super ego to say nah bro that
that's weird don't do that however it's
not good when a normal and healthy
desire gets repressed in fact that can
come with some serious side effects it's
like the unconscious version of what
happens when the adults in the footloose
town forbid the teens from dancing if
you tell the kids they can't dance
they're just going to want to dance more
[Music]
and may realizes the side effects of her
repression pretty quickly when she wakes
up the next morning as a giant red panda
this transformation literalizes some of
her fears and shame namely that having
normal teenage desires is turning her
into a monster and of course the movie
isn't not using this as an allegory for
a young woman getting her first period
as mei's mother's initial reaction is to
get her ibuprofen and a shocking variety
of pads but the film uses the
specificity of may's experience of
transitioning into womanhood to make a
much broader point about the role of
repression we learn early on that the
panda is brought out by strong emotions
and it's not just negative emotions even
a box full of adorable pixar kittens
threatens to unleash the beast but this
paints a clear message strong emotions
of any kind are bad and should be kept
inside where they can't cause any harm
now mae learns that one of her ancestors
asked to be turned into a red panda to
defend her family while the men were
away at war ever since each woman in her
lineage has developed a panda of their
own however they've all gone through a
religious ceremony to separate from
their panda trapping its essence in a
piece of jewelry or other token if mei
can just make it to the next red moon
she can exercise that furry critter for
good but in the meantime being forced to
contain her panda just furthers may's
established pattern of repression her
experience of sexual desire led to shame
and guilt which caused the panda to
emerge and now to keep the panda at bay
she needs to repress any further desires
and emotions even positive ones so that
she can remain a model student without
revealing her very furry family secret
now we already talked about the super
ego that part of the unconscious that
sets up all types of rules and
regulations so that our scumbag id can't
run rampant and may with the help of her
family's mythology takes on a new
superego structure specifically designed
to repress the hell out of that adorable
panda happy oh yeah
that's the stuff but even with this
family narrative mae slowly embraces her
emotions and passions and starts turning
panda whenever she feels like it though
she's supposed to keep her panda at bay
until the ritual she realizes being a
panda is as you might expect super fun
not to mention quite financially
lucrative and her best friends encourage
it noting that it's bringing out a whole
new side of may that they really love
you really changed and
i'm proud of you
just
don't get rid of all of it however in
doing this mei's once lorelei and rory
relationship with her mother begins to
slowly fracture and to understand this
fracturing mother-daughter relationship
we need to kiss freud goodbye as he was
notorious for framing psychological
development around male sexuality and
that's led many subsequent theorists to
worry that thinkers like freud fail to
adequately understand the particulars of
female sexual development this is
exactly what bulgarian french theorist
julia kristeva thought her own account
of psychosexual development lands with
the symbolic stage i.e when children
enter the world of linguistic
communication social relations the law
et cetera during this phase a child
develops a sense of identity that is
separate from the mother and this
process involves something called
abjection objection basically happens
when we encounter a rupture specifically
the distinction between our self and the
other this causes a breakdown in our
sense of meaning according to christeva
the abject confronts us with our
earliest attempts to release the hold of
maternal entity even before existing
outside of her thanks to the autonomy of
language it is a violent clumsy breaking
away with the constant risk of falling
back under the sway of a power as
securing as it is stifling surprisingly
realizing that you are not one and the
same as your mom can be pretty upsetting
a very gnarly example of this would be
that seeing a corpse for the first time
is a traumatic reminder that we too are
a body made of material stuff that is
one day going to die and decay in a less
gnarly but still gross example this can
also happen when we see an open wound or
like
fecal matter as it reminds us that our
own bodies are full of blood and
and we're basically animals but also
human but still animal which is super
confusing in particular christeva
associates this process with the
maternal figure and that horrifying
moment in which we separate ourselves
from our mother also important to note
that christeva's account doesn't map on
to the same age progression as freud's
with much of this development taking
place from birth through age four though
it repeats throughout life for christeva
experiencing the abject is a necessary
part of the development process on the
individual's way to language and a full
self-consciousness or as christeva puts
it objection is a precondition of
narcissism with narcissism here being
less about loving to look in the mirror
and more about recognizing that there's
a u to look at in the mirror in the
first place now turning red definitely
hints at the idea that dropping your
uterine lining can provide an abject
experience which can lead to distancing
from the mother even if she's not
curse was a curse of blood that said
this is only hinted at and not
explicitly explored in the movie which
is why we're more interested in the
film's primary metaphor for the abject
which is of course the red panda it puts
may at the unstable boundary of the
human and the animal she wants to just
be a normal human kid but is haunted by
this wild animal that exists within her
it's an identity crisis that christeva
might have warned could lead to
melancholia depression and even
aggressive acting out which we see in
both mei's initial reaction to becoming
panda and her near murder of her nelly
idolizing classmate tyler so how do we
deal with these abject experiences that
send our fragile developing egos reeling
christeva says that both art and
religion can serve the purpose of
purifying the abject i.e they give us
images and narratives that make gross
stuff feel less gross and we see
something similar happening in the film
first the mythology around mae's family
lineage is represented in art throughout
the temple which shows her brave
ancestor who took on the whole panda bit
to protect her family this turns the
potentially aggressive and frightening
animality of the panda into a story
about courage and bravery and of course
the panda can only be truly purified
from maze person via a ritual that takes
place during a red moon chrysteva says
that the various means of purifying the
abject make up the history of religions
and end up with that catharsis par
excellence called art and in may's case
it's very clear that much of her
family's own mythology and religious
practice serve this very purpose to
purify the dangerous animal and make it
part of a larger narrative but to be
clear for christeva this purifying is
not necessarily a good thing rather it's
a process by which we avoid directly
confronting the horrifying and upsetting
aspects of our own humanity she sees art
and religion as attempting to wallpaper
over the breakdowns associated with the
abject but back to our ritual may gets
sort of teleported up to an ancestral
realm where she's led to separate
herself from her panda but right at the
crucial moment where she is about to be
purified of this seemingly abject thing
once and for all she re-merges with it
comes back to earth embodying her panda
and joyfully flies over toronto's
rooftops on her way to the four-town
concert and yes just like may's mom
we can't stop wondering why it's called
four-town if there are five of them is
one of them is one of them meant to be
the town
right like out of the work at this
moment rather than continue to repress
the panda she embraces it as one aspect
of her complex self in this way she is
accepting the split nature of her own
subjectivity or personhood or um panda
hood rather than seeking some unifying
sense of self it's accepting rather than
purifying this abject thing the point
isn't to push the bad stuff away it's to
make room for it
live with it this is great for may not
so great for her mother ming who nearly
loses her damn mind releases her own
truly terrifying panda and goes on a
legit rampage the size of ming's panda
seems like a kind of metaphor for what
happens when strong feelings are
repressed for decades and the toxic
effect this can have on the psyche and
it's hinted at throughout the film that
ming has a less than healthy
relationship with her own mother me it's
your mother i'm not here
a relationship that seems to be marked
by the type of depression and
melancholia that christeva associates
with female children's inability to
fully separate from their mothers and
speaking of mae's grandmother eventually
all the women in her family unleash
their own pandas showing that when they
use their passion for a purpose it's not
all bad after ming grandma and the
aunties all return their pandas back to
the ancestral realm may reaffirms her
commitment to accepting her panda and
keeping it as an unrepressed part of her
identity i'm changing mom
i'm finally figuring out who i am she
knows that in doing so she will be
severing her bond with her mother one
that ming has tried to maintain
throughout the film in embracing the
panda it's as if mae is acknowledging
the fundamental separation between her
mother and herself an acknowledgement
that's crucial to growing up and it's
not a stretch to say that this theme in
particular is pretty autobiographical
for writer and director domi she who in
an interview recounts the emotional
words of her mother the sentence she
heard upon each visit home after moving
out oh domi i wish i could put you back
in my stomach so i knew exactly where
you were at all times but instead may is
out of ming's womb and finally partying
at the all age karaoke spot ready to get
your karaoke on totally by its end the
film seems to be a sort of warning
against the shame and subsequent
repression experienced by young people
who are coming of age along with an
endorsement of embracing and affirming
some of the more abject aspects of their
identities in doing so turning red
challenges us to embrace all the weird
and embarrassing aspects of ourselves
even the really gross stuff
but what do you guys think is turning
red going to help a lot of young folks
accept their desires rather than
repressing them can we accept our
animality and cope with the fact that
our bodies make weird fluids sometimes
or should we just shut up and get good
grades because that's our only hope let
us know what you think in the comments
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our
revamp patreon page there's lots of cool
stuff there we think you'll love it
obliterate that subscribe button like
it's a naughty boy band leading your
daughter into sin and don't forget to
ring that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
you